i still hate doing intros but it's kind
of obligatory with these kinds of videos
so i will say that this is the first
comment reading video you guys have
comments questions concerns maybe
and if you don't get them answered in
this video throw them in the comments in
this video and i will get to you on the
next one but for now
we're gonna be looking at the channel
update video see what you guys are
saying most of you guys are chill
and cool and then there's some people
who like to throw a pebble my way every
once in a while
and i'll be happy to entertain those
people also depending on how rational
they are
but uh let's get into it and see what
you guys are saying cynical cardi
remember me when you're famous
i don't think i'm getting famous for
doing a recap channel for anime but uh
you know what cynical cardi i'll do my
best i don't think it's gonna be hard i
just don't think that i'm going to have
that many fans but
i'll keep you in mind all right i'll jot
this down and commit you to memory
gotcha oh boy here we go haraz
fatih fatih i'm just going to assume
that it's harassed fatigue
also can i please have a piece of merch
i don't have money to support you
that's crazy coincidence i don't have
money to support you either so uh no
but what we can do is form a support
group dedicated towards learning how to
support other people
so that you can learn how to support me
with money and then i'll learn how to
support you with a shirt
by the way why do you look like you're
out of the witness protection program
what is this picture it looks like a
crazy girlfriend cut off your face and
is about to put another man's face on
top of it
i think that this could be a scam
account now that i'm looking at it
because it seems like you're really
pushing for free [ __ ]
and then on top of that you're really
protective of your identity
you got a little operation going on
garage maybe i won it
you game a barcode says i love you and i
miss you
and i i feel like this is another scam
account because you're right next to our
raws
i feel like i'm getting wrapped up in
some sort of crime ring right now
because you can't miss me you don't know
me
nobody knows about my channel in real
life like i don't tell anybody because
it's like
like what am i gonna oh yeah i uh recap
anime for a living they're like oh
[ __ ] i'm so wet it's like i i know sorry
i'm sorry i'll get them up it's fine
plus you have a barcode why do you have
a barcode on youtube barcode and horaz
are up to something i'm calling it now
don't mess with me barcode okay
i have like six comp size students in my
discord right now
they'll [ __ ] destroy you okay and
then one of them will make a game about
how badly they destroyed you so don't
come at us okay let's all just calm down
no free [ __ ] okay barcode you and harass
no merch
no merch barcode saya here
shukran if you're foreign and i butcher
your name
it's just what i do like if you watch my
earlier videos people [ __ ] hate the
way i say names commenting to help with
the algorithm ah [ __ ] and then he's like
the nicest guy ever thanks a lot man i
appreciate it sorry about the name
what happened qui lee welcome back hey
man thanks for having me i think there's
been a lot of stuff going on so there's
been a lot of breaks in the content
recently i'm trying to get it back on
track but there's just
you know it's uh one of those things
life you know unknown
black profile picture harass and bar
code are up to something and they
brought the squad
and everybody's doubting me and the
proof is right here tier list you know
the foot picks meme
what are we even talking about tier list
you know the foot picks meme
are you calling me tier list or is that
like a separate thought
you know the foot picks me is there like
a foot picks meme tier list
man you took me on a roller coaster
right there man
i don't appreciate it robbie mayhem
sounds like a bdsm porn star name i'm
not saying that i'm like
familiar with the naming schemes of bds
and porn stars it just seems like
if you were a bdsm porn star named
robbie mayhem
i think you would make a killing robbie
mayhem here
[ __ ] [ __ ] up whoosh
l4xph i really like your vids also good
luck hey thanks man alfred's ph
good luck to you also all right i don't
know what endeavors you're undergoing in
your life but i'm sure you'll do great
raj rock another porn star name continue
your playlist
keep updating continue my playlist
i'll keep updating all of the playlists
how's that yoon jo
chung a hashtag oh somebody finally used
the hashtag attention [ __ ]
look you guys i was [ __ ] around you
don't actually have to put hashtag
attention over but hey
congrats on accepting yourself that's
great wow did not expect this
i mean yes this video but also your raw
thoughts and humor
it was nice also your voice plus content
is amazing
just do you glad you found a way to
continue the channel
and i hope for the best oh what the [ __ ]
why are you so nice
what is this you working with her [ __ ] i
forgot his name hold on
barcode and hurrahs
you're like the sleeper cell huh like in
case things go south with them and then
you're there to like pick up the pieces
and put it all back together
save the whole operation so it's not a
waste on to you right
you're too nice for the internet [ __ ]
out of here [ __ ] out of here
i appreciate it man thanks so much john
luke sabios
okay here's my feedback improve your
voice audio quality
i can barely hear you in this video how
is it that you're the only one with this
problem if it was a common thing
sure you know there's volume right what
do you mean you can barely hear me
you have speakers right there's a knob
just it's to the right man to the right
usually does it
unknown again black picture keeping an
eye on you and haraz why did you
jump on the redo of a healer hate train
i don't know how many people have spoken
about that [ __ ] storm so far
but it should be good for views if you
forgot the rape and
sex then the fights are decent you guys
just forget the rape and sex
piece of fighting so i mean i have
come across it i have researched
the topic interesting show interesting
show
miriam rasheed oh my god your best
videos have been taken down
are you kidding me crying crying face
will you be re-uploading any of this
stuff good question no
and the reason is if you go under
re-zero there's like no videos on there
so i think when it comes to
catecholacorp they just really like
[ __ ]
youtubers out of using their content for
for now i'm just gonna lay low i think
so
i'm sorry guys i know it's shitty but
it's like that's i'm just gonna play by
the rules for now
ethmoir you should do black clover i
should do black clover and i probably
will at some point so uh stay tuned
oh god here we go now we're just getting
into all the [ __ ] recap requests can
you do a recap of psych you know i i
don't even know what that is to be
honest with you man
uh probably at some point if it's if
there's a new season coming out i
definitely will cover it if not
50 50 we'll see sorry man lazy sloth
please make psycho pass season three
food wars season four
and five psycho pass is such a god damn
nightmare to cover
that show is the one show where i like
genuinely
have no [ __ ] idea what's going on
like ever like all the characters are
just like
who every every season there's like a
new group of characters i'm just like
who the [ __ ] are these people
how do they get how are they here who
are they they're just working here now
i may have made a tiny bit of a mistake
because i had sorted the comments by top
and i meant to do it by newest so now
these are the oldest comments on the
video there's like 172 comments on this
video i did not realize this so i'm
gonna try
and speed this up a little bit do my
best okay i will get you eventually i'm
doing my best give me a break okay
dark wow i forgot i was subscribed to
this channel that means unforgettable
[ __ ] you right two upvotes [ __ ] you guys
what are you doing
michael wreck good to see you back good
to be back thank you for having me yummy
rage i thought you were going to leave
us forever
sad crying face [ __ ] you yummy don't let
copyright keep you down oh thanks
27 upvotes wow yeah i mean kind of
famous ace mitten
man you scared me scare face i thought
this channel was gonna go and i love
your videos i love you
erica blake looking forward to your want
what to know and season review videos
yes
i don't know how they're going to turn
out low expectations erica don't look
forward to it okay
e outfricksph i really like your videos
and also good luck thanks man good oh
wait i think i read you [ __ ] out of here
ivan any format and videos will get my
support
i like you ivan i like your support also
hurrahs
you [ __ ] you did multiple
comments on here a recap of
hx oh hunter x hunter love your videos
by the way hey thanks man uh hunter x
hunter
that's a lot of that's a lot of episodes
i'll think about it maybe at some point
not right now though
it's going to be a little bit until i
get around to like the longer long form
season reviews
also do a recap of gto a very good show
gto i'm sure i know if i hear it but
i don't recognize the acronym a very
good show it probably is i'll try and
get around to also please do it you're
just [ __ ] naming all the shows you
like man
what are you talking about i can't just
do all of your shows this isn't about
you
haraz it's not about you no free merch
haraz [ __ ] out of here also please do a
recap if not food and black clover
black clover i've been cut i mean in
this video alone i'm getting tons of
black clover so i'll probably do that at
some point gto is not full hx
i read it the first time harass what are
we doing here
kyrie mac to be honest i would probably
watch anything you produce your quality
and feedback is just amazing debatable
thank you that was really nice
oh i gave you a heart you earned it good
job 39 upvotes thank you guys
so nice shs smh you have a problem stop
commenting also for recaps i suggest the
fate series i suggest you stop
commenting i'll have it uh phoenix
haven't seen you in a while man welcome
back thanks for having me
haraz [ __ ] also can you please
oh this is the merch this is when you
ask merch you make all the requests and
then at the end you're like oh by the
way
give me a [ __ ] shirt no haraz [ __ ]
out of here alam
hey i'm glad you were back and made the
update video and also dot
dot read more the discord link is
invalid please send it
i know all right i fixed it alarm go
join
and then tell me that you were alarmed
so i can yell at you for yelling at me
for
already fixing it and then not you you
not realizing that i fixed it okay
the oh the the discord's like dying
right now you guys i read a eulogy for
the for the other day but nobody was
around to like
appreciate it so if you guys could like
go to the discord and then just like
talk in the discord
a general chat yeah just go into general
chat and then just make it seem alive
so i could feel alive also for like a
day at least
that'd be really nice but you know
you're not dudes whatever discord link
isn't working [ __ ]
0401 very pogers i'd honestly watch
anything you produce
porn you win plasma
1 5 this man is the first person
i've ever met that is so chill while
roasting the crap out of people
by the way i didn't skip a single bit so
you can give me
that metal uh thanks plasma do i know
you plasma were you in the discord i
flipped the [ __ ] out of people on
discord if you walk into discord you are
walking through a gauntlet of my insults
and if you can survive it i'm pretty
cool at the end like if you could take
it that's great
big body boy channel is way too
professional for 20k
series oh thanks
big body boy again i've watched every
vid i'll watch
any video upload lol you better be here
[ __ ] if i don't see you in the
comments
[ __ ] liar i'm gonna find you joint
discord also i want to talk to you
you're beautiful
back zach the only feedback i can give
you is this the channel is great and
nothing really needs to change keep it
up
wow thanks so much man a lot is changing
though so uh
no i just no i'm not gonna listen to
that be bad but i will say
you're nice thank you hello the outro
the outro people if you didn't watch the
outro you missed out
on a historic event for the channel
watch the outro
rachel solaris i definitely watched the
recaps from older animes i'd stay
i stayed to the complete and by the way
why are you guys so [ __ ] beautiful
why do you guys do this stop staying to
the end of videos
ninety percent of the time it's a waste
of time i'm in the ten percent
all right enjoy being in the ten percent
with me right josh mindy right
you really took some of the anime recaps
that i wanted to watch i know i'm sorry
man i didn't
okay katakana corp did the outro so
funny why are you guys so cool why did
you watch to the outro nobody watches
outros
you guys are beautiful stop i'm gonna
cry stop wait david's
personally i would like different videos
to go with a recap and i need one piece
recap
if another person asked me for a one
piece it's 900
episode it's like a thousand episodes i
also think that social media is like
discord and reddit can be great for the
channel thanks for doing amazing videos
the discord was a huge failure it's dead
lathe go join [ __ ]
joel ae oh joel i i recognize you i
recognize your name we've talked before
for the algorithm if it miss you can cut
this stupid [ __ ] clock who thought
this clock was a good idea it just makes
bird sounds
right in the middle of joel i'm sorry
joel okay just ignore it
[ __ ] clock is [ __ ] if it miss you
can cut the production
and ship to another anime that may
attract more people
it sounds silly but it seems like it
seems to work for many
channels well if many channels are doing
it why would i do it joel
i'm supposed to be original episode by
episode that's why that's like my
strength
samuth shetty i recognize your profile
picture you are amazing i would love to
see different video formats thank you so
much for for making videos
i was wondering if you ever did a
re-zero recap but i understood now what
happened to be honest
i would watch any kind of content with
you in it could be anything anime review
gaming reaction as long as you are there
because in it's the person which makes
the video good been here for a long time
and don't plan on changing that anytime
soon
hashtag attention [ __ ] hey i got you
man wow
that was super nice i have thought about
doing other content probably not going
to
i feel like the problem with me
branching into like
different content outside of anime which
i would love to do because i think i'd
be way better at it i think the problem
is that i like baited people
into like hey you want you want anime
recaps come on
and i just hard switched like no i'm a
gaming channel let's go play
fortnite everybody like it would be a
[ __ ] thing to do so i mean
maybe someday i can like dabble in other
stuff but i feel weird moving away from
it and like completely
shutting out the um anime aspect of my
content creation but i
appreciate you sticking around and like
you know wanting to [ __ ] with my content
that's super nice of you thanks man
not victor cah three there's spaces
there's a space bar for a reason
i'm not even gonna repeat your name you
know who you are [ __ ] keep up the
great work oh keep up the great work
consistency and quality man let's go
hey thanks man aaron yeager you
[ __ ] you got that name really i hate
intros i love it i love you
and i really do hate intros you saw the
[ __ ] intro to this [ __ ]
ooh man here we go sue john why is there
an h at the end of your name
sync is it supposed to make a sound
please do a one piece you [ __ ]
out it's luck gg this was so funny
thanks man you're nice everybody else is
so weird
see me jane amazing ideas we'll be
waiting for the new videos to get
uploaded soon
uh yeah i don't know if you should don't
wait around okay they're kind of
they're kind of disappointing your
recaps are your recap videos are amazing
they're they're a lifesaver for me i was
wondering whether you could do
recap videos of anime like black clover
man there's a lot of people for black
clover you guys are you guys are kind of
waiting me over this is why you comment
i told you guys to comment the video but
nobody listens hashtag attention [ __ ]
man of honor is your channel
is like a team management channel or is
not
is it not a team management channel do
you mean am i working with other people
i could manage a team i don't because i
am broke
as [ __ ] i could easily do it like that
but no it's not a team management
channel i
i think i'm guessing that's what you
mean kadee liverton hey
maybe you could try doing reactions to
shows i know that's a pretty big jump
from your
normal content but i think that
reactions would work out great because
your sense of humor is pretty good and
heck you just rambling [ __ ] at the
end was pretty funny
more importantly you can do a lot of
stuff on patreon with reactions like
early access
extra reactions and uh uncut reactions
it's actually not a bad idea
i think that if you guys watched that
kind of content i could make like any
content
oh i was you egotistical wow this is not
true
i don't know i said that i think like
reaction stuff and like anime
and gaming i think i could do a lot of
that but when it comes what it comes
down to is like
is there an audience that would follow
me over through that transformation
and that transition i'm gonna go ahead
and say no
but then again a lot of people haven't
seen videos like this where i'm just
kind of being myself
and shooting this [ __ ] with people so i
mean maybe someday if i get enough of a
following and people
that's like a consistent goal that
people kind of see
that they want me to pursue then i of
course i have no problem doing stuff
like that jack mossy mosey
uh i wish i could watch all of your
videos but i do sometimes skip your
videos of the shows i've already seen
also i love the way you talk it's super
unique people
hate it man like they that's probably
like the most complain thing
i get or thing that people complain
about the most is the way i
enunciate things and then i slow down
and i talk like this and i spur on and
then i
talk a little bit slower people just
don't like it i think it's like a love
hate thing you're a legend this is
exactly
what people need and no matter the
barriers i hope you know
how much people appreciate this hey i
don't know because not enough people
like you are kind enough to tell me but
i'm sure that there are people out there
who are affected
in a positive way and so that makes me
happy so thanks for coming on saying so
man
temboshi uh barcode [ __ ]
omar h can't wait for the two hour video
of what to know
of attack on titan i don't think i'm
gonna make one video covering
all of attack on titan i usually do it
season my season
so i mean you could just like binge
watch those and get the general gist of
of what's going on so i i don't i don't
think it'll be a two-hour video though
hey oh my early attack on titan videos
are [ __ ] trash good luck
aa111102 goat saved me a lot of time
blessed be
blessed would be my friend uh alankara
man you could post anything and i would
still watch you're amazing and deserve
more hype
but question do you still have do you
have an annalist account i don't have an
annualist account i do but like i don't
use it for like anything specific i just
kind of
use it to like research shows and stuff
but i appreciate the kind words cbz
memes love you so much bro i'm waiting
for the
a re-zero recap so i can continue the
series did you even watch the video man
i i can't i can't do it i said it in the
video what are you talking about mr
lollipop this channel has helped me
a lot keep it up gonna keep keeping it
up thanks man me
oh here we go oh i recognize you we
talked uh me you we uh no
look we've talked i mean well okay moo
yiwa
olanian if it means anything i actually
love your voice
it's it's a staple of the channel i
disagree i think that's the one thing i
just can't accept my voice look you guys
can stroke my voice all you want
i just don't like it it's just one of
those things i sound like a little [ __ ]
let's let's be honest it's like it's
pretty high pitch
like you know how i can you know i can
you know i can handle you those little
high notes like yeah
yeah that's not good i'm a man i
shouldn't be able to do that the highest
i should go
is right here this should be this is
like a normal man's high voice
alvaro aviles it's so good to finally
see you again we miss you so much
i think somebody already said it but in
the comments but i will watch any kind
of series you make i also had an idea
of a kind of seasonal series on which
just before a new
season arrives you make recaps of the
sequels there will be
you want me to do recaps of upcoming
shows and do the prior seasons which is
exactly what i do i think that's what
you're saying though i could be
misinterpreting
i'm not going to read all of that again
because it was really long but i think
that's what you're saying if i
misinterpreted throw in the comment in
this video i just baited you into the
commenting in this video get [ __ ]
idiot all right and then we got xfinity
x
infin infinite shock darn i j i was just
about to start re zero season two part
two but nevertheless you were doing
god's work
hey i'm sorry man i'm i really i feel
bad about it
and a lot of people like those re zero
videos and ah
i really wish i could get the money that
came with it also
for rai hondina
man yes let's do the classics i'm just
hungry for your content thanks man ah
classic someday okay someday once we
have team management we'll do the
classics
sakil kumar this guy is just waiting to
blow up by the way kingdom recap this
guy's voice
is acquired as an acquired taste that's
putting it nicely ebber quintero
let's go more content what i'm saying
seba i don't usually comment on youtube
videos but man the effort you put in
doing videos really impresses me
i know you hear it a lot but never but
it's never too much you deserve more
thanks so much man i think a lot of
people
really don't understand how much work i
put into each video
and it's not like an ego thing or like
hey praise me [ __ ] like i do it
because i want to make good content
i don't like tik tok and [ __ ] because
it's like it's just so lazy and i don't
want to be lazy
but it comes at a price man it's like
the time investment is so insane
i was a huge ego stroke for myself you
guys like that you like me just stroking
myself off on camera
esri johnson i'm gonna join uh what's
his face
something mayhem he's gonna be my bdsm
porn partner esri johnson love your
videos keep up the good work by the way
you should do
how not to summon a demon lord since
season two is fin to start
if in the end i think it already did end
actually and i already covered it man so
uh enjoy that
corymanics thomas just came across your
channel automatic sub i'll be here to
get uh to see how this channel
progresses can't wait to
uh see what co oh my god i'm just like
the speed round is going it's it's
dragging on i'm like wavering right now
let me i'm just going to take it right
i'm going to take a breather okay
intermission over i
got water i turned on the ac for a
little bit it's super [ __ ] hot in
here but it's
loud so i can't just let the ac run
everything is good though i'm refocused
revamped re-energized
my voice is kind of going so uh bear
with me but core
corey mannix thomas just came across the
channel automatic sub i'll be here to
see how the channel progresses can't
wait to see what uh what comes next bro
thanks so much man i can't promise it's
anything good but
as long as you're here that's all that
matters to me man today uh
glad you're coming back love this
channel love you perler toner uh love
the idea of starting review
videos as much as i love your recap
videos they only have one target
audience people who have already seen
the anime who don't rem
who want to remember what happens review
videos would be fantastic way to branch
and get a larger audience especially
with how good your editing
and charisma are best of luck this year
thanks so much man i don't know about
the charisma but uh the editing i would
like to say i'm improving on it's a
working pro
everything's just a work of progress
we're gonna see how things go but i
appreciate it man hopefully hopefully
things
continue on an upward trajectory david
lowen damn you funny as [ __ ] damn you
funny as [ __ ] boy
right king i'd watch any video you post
to be honest porn me and
uh what's his face um ah [ __ ] i just
mayhem me and mayhem are gonna make a
porn video stay tuned for that uh khaled
x i keep up the hard work man really
makes my days could you do one piece no
[ __ ] all right it's a thousand
episodes my voice is already going why
do you have to make me yell
jeremaine savory bro your channel is
amazing bro you're amazing
lucas d'angelo uh yes and one piece
recap would be awesome [ __ ] out out
out laughing at this video is hilarious
also please do
no oh don't start with a [ __ ]
compliment and then make me get mad at
you get the [ __ ] out give the [ __ ] out
but uh thanks for the kind words uh eco
ramen new sub very useful for people
who have a hard time remembering what
they've watched exactly what the
the channels for install the rodent what
the [ __ ] is that name
i needed a break anyways but like let's
just stop here and stall the rodent
that sounds like a euphemism like i'm
about to install my rodent you ready
me and me and mayhem pornhub check it
out
coming soon i'm gonna install the rodent
that's gonna be the catchphrase and the
the title of the video i'm waiting for
the day this channel blows up me too
[ __ ]
uh spin a journey oh my god okay say
sayokujin's child oh that wasn't as bad
as i thought it'd be if you do one piece
or bleach that'd be cool epic cash money
for at least for me every cash money uh
like it wouldn't be epic cash money
every cash money for who
i don't get money for the shows i cover
now and then i'm gonna dump a bunch of
time into it and then i'm not gonna get
any money
i pay cash money i'm not gonna get any
[ __ ] money epic cash money
uh here oh boy see ya here
shukron oh wait i [ __ ] read it god
you made me say your name twice out
avalon uh can you do a recap of so i
read you too
korea i'm just here to tell you that i
truly seriously and honestly appreciate
every little bit of effort
in creating your recaps handstand hands
down to you hoping to see more of your
videos also looking forward to the day
that when you get thousands of millions
of subs
keep up with a great job and stay safe
hey you stay safe too
that's my wait have i responded to you
that's usually what i respond to people
stay safe hey guys stay safe i wouldn't
mind one piece of content i know you
wouldn't mind i would
cora that sucks that you can't do
re-zero because i
i have no idea what's going on in that
show anymore nobody does okay that's why
i made the show
or the other recap ellis lily honestly
you should do some old anime i would
freaking love that
uh old anime i'm guessing we're talking
about what piece of all that [ __ ] i did
with concert or get consider get do we
get okay um
i think i read this okay here's my
feedback approved oh yeah you
oh we're back to you out [ __ ]
can you hear that
do you need to turn your volume up
mm-hmm one tree
i would watch the one-piece recap i know
you would there's like a handful of you
that would but it's so much work you
guys
too much work okay uh a h would you do a
uh would you do a recap for re zero i
desperately need that lol
did you watch the video man it's in the
video i can't make it i can't make a
reason to recap okay uh
blue raptors four category animes you
should do so okay
pictures good idea uh nick love how i
got how did you get nick for an id
love how i got an ad at the end wasn't
the ending worth it though i mean
you kind of had to pay me for that one
right uh luis
wise i actually don't know this guy's
content but he's currently my biggest
subscriber like he has the biggest
channel that subscribed to me i think
he's on like
500 000 um 500 000 subs
488 000 so go check him out he seems
like a cool guy
channel has huge potential keep it
please keep it up dude thanks so much
um yeah he seems like a cool guy seems
like nice guy 155 it could be valuable
for longer shows like one piece if
you've actually seen it but i think your
core audience is people who solve season
one the studio took
the like three years to make season two
and now they don't remember
what happened in the first part so tldr
my advice
is stick with current season animes like
you have been
thank you man i will take it into
consideration i really don't know what
the [ __ ] i'm doing at this point if i
if i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up and it's fine but
i appreciate it thanks man
uh ushima she's oh boy zuru
did you come before is there anyone in
with a backup of the reason
there's no backup okay there's no backup
you [ __ ] out the [ __ ] out marshall d
teach suggestion recaps and what to know
here a separate dedicated channel for
reviews
and you can review not only seasons but
also episodes
or manga or and or anything tailored to
your liking
it will be richer and with more room to
to breathe thanks for all your hard work
the problem with that is like it's so
hard
to get people to follow your channel the
first time but then they have to be a
big enough fan to oh
my god this clock is gonna [ __ ] kill
me okay
make your noises clock it's fine i'm not
upset it's fine it's not
my clock not insulting the person who
put it here it's just
ruining my shot it's fine i don't want
to do
um a separate channel just because it's
hard to convince people
to like subscribe to this one and then
go to the second one and subscribe
it's like uh it just seems like an added
step and a lot of people are lazy as
[ __ ] so they just don't want to go and
do that
nadar that's kind of cool name just
commenting to support the channel love
your work no need to make it awkward
have a nice day
i'm not making it awkward are you making
it awkward wait kind of like me or
something that make it awkward man
like i think you made it awkward i don't
know why you made me make it awkward i
mean you made me make it awkward so i
mean you made it awkward hurry tan
you're keeping the channel alive you're
a legend appreciate it from france from
france
some [ __ ] like that shinobi you're
finally back i am back oliver queen
recognize your uh thumbnail
our uh profile picture we've talked
before seeing how uh seeing how
entertaining this video was through
though it was to give us information i
really think you should start doing the
reviews
and if possible even the anime season in
a nutshell kind of videos
probably not with the same title though
cause [ __ ]
but what what i don't know what that is
uh but i'll be here to support you no
matter what you decide to do
p.s i'm not earning just yet but once i
get a job
i'll become a patreon or buy the merch
well thanks man like i you guys don't
need to do
all that [ __ ] it's fine like i'm doing
fine like don't worry about it okay but
i appreciate it i recognize you've been
here for a long time man i remember
talking to you a long time ago
so it's super nice of you thanks for the
continued support cinderkit
five gear channels that has the best
anime recaps man i love them i love you
rev rivaldo smith you got a cool voice
bro debatable but uh i appreciate it
robbie may
robbie mayhem that's what it was robbie
i uh i'm leaving this comment for the
medish oh wait i already read it [ __ ]
out
raj uh raj rock oh yeah oh you guys were
right by each other i said that that
would sound like a porn name too
install the rodent back at it hashtag
at relax recap you don't have to add in
youtube comments
i love your channel uh thanks for saving
me over 20 hours on anime because i'm
too lazy to re-watch
hope your channel blows up thanks so
much man you're uh you're awesome keep
watching and
keep supporting the channel i love you
good luck all right carl benedict
garc scarces it's really great that you
have been able to recover from this
i mean it wasn't really recovering but
yeah thank you for doing this again
hoping that you'll be able to make more
yeah it wasn't really i wouldn't say it
was a recovery it wasn't like i was
canceled and then i came back was like
i'm back [ __ ] it was like if
some i know i took a hit on some of the
income
loss i mean it sucked but yeah i
wouldn't say it was a recovery though
your channel is amazing thanks oh all
right you're amazing heart i
already responded you're welcome you
should do sao
dead out dead to me out watch the video
i can't all right
good oh god
oh yeah 172 comments accounted for
answered and taken care of god i feel
like i was just seeing
one of robbie mayhem's bdsm videos it's
like a million degrees in here
if you guys liked this video i
appreciate it this was actually a lot of
fun i had a lot of fun making this video
probably the most fun i've ever had
making a video so hopefully
you guys enjoyed it and if you didn't
that's okay too i don't
you don't need to tell me that if you
guys did like it throw it in the
comments if you didn't get your comment
responded to
throw it in this comment section and i'm
gonna make another follow-up video
for this comment section also and that
we could just make a little bit of a
series out of it if that's cool i mean
if you guys are liking it then i can
keep doing it i like talking to you guys
and some of you might want to talk to me
and i'm more than happy to do that
so i thank you for stopping by all that
stuff this isn't an outro though okay
don't get [ __ ] twisted
this isn't an outro this is just me
saying that you guys need to go
and check out robbie b mayhem at
p-hub.com okay good luck bdsm category
good luck
you